-It's great to see you, and
thanks for being on the show.
I want to talk about
"Wakanda Forever,"
but can we just talk about --
"Black Panther" was your --
was that your first role?
No?
-Was, indeed, my first role.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm sorry.
Your first role?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Not too shabby, huh?
-Not too shabby at all.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-It's -- It was very just, like,
mind-blowing showing up
on set the first day.
And it's like, okay,
turn left, Angela Bassett.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. And now "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever."
Everyone cannot wait
to see this.
November 11th.
We're all psyched to see it.
It's bigger, it's just giant,
action-packed.
But then we just heard
that Rihanna has a song in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The Queen.
The Queen herself.
-And that's her first song
in six years.
-[ Laughs ]
-Everyone's going crazy for it.
-This is what the wait was for.
They were just -- we were just
waiting for "Wakanda Forever."
-Yeah.
Have you gotten --
Did you ever get to --
Did you get to meet Rihanna?
-I did.
I got to meet Rihanna in 2019.
-Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, wait till
you hear the story, so...
[ Laughter ]
I never --
I have to say,
I never get starstruck,
and that was the night.
-Really?
-I had a lot of, like,
plans in my head for years.
Because we're both Caribbean.
I'm from Trinidad.
She's from Barbados.
You know,
and I had all these ideas.
I'm like, "I'm gonna
chat her up on like Carnivale,
Crop Over, talk about art."
-Yes!
-You know, we've got some vibes.
I was like, "We got this."
[ Laughter ]
And then, I saw her,
and a friend introduced,
and I was like,
"Hey, you know, my friend
wasn't supposed to be so crass.
You know, he knows I love you."
And she goes, "Oh, thank you,
thank you, thank you."
And I was like, "I'm Winston,
Winston Duke."
She was like,
"I'm aware of who you are."
[ Laughter ]
And she looked at me.
She was like, "Yeah, I know
exactly who you are."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Ah, ha!"
-She froze you up?
-Oh, I folded.
-Really?
-Like fresh laundry, my friend.
I was --
[ Laughter ]
I was -- I was stunned.
I was like, "So, um, buh, bah --
Well, uh,
where'd you come from?"
[ Laughter ]
That was it!
That was my line.
That was it.
That's what came out.
-You've been waiting to meet
Rihanna your whole --
-And I said,
"Where'd you come from?"
And she said, "Uh, my house."
[ Laughter ]
And I aborted.
-"I came from my house."
-No, no, I aborted.
I aborted immediately.
I was like, "It's such
a pleasure meeting you,"
and I walked off,
and my boy came, was like,
"So, how'd it go?"
and I was like,
"I asked her
where she was from."
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
♪ Bwah, bwah, bwah ♪
[ Laughter ]
And he was like,
"From heaven, fool!
You know!
You know where she's from!"
-From heaven, yeah.
-"Go back, go back.
Get on the horse,
get back on the horse."
And I was like, "No, man."
-She must have loved you,
though, because she asked you to
be in her upcoming fashion show.
-Yes, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, come on.
-You know,
the legs will be out.
-Oh. Thank you.
Congratulations on that.
-The legs will be oiled,
and they're gonna be out.
I will be a savage Fenty man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
-"Wakanda Forever,"
the movie pays tribute
to Chadwick Boseman,
who we're all so sad
that he's not with us.
It must have been difficult
to film this.
-Yeah.
I mean, it was very --
Just a lot of emotions
every day, a lot of grief.
And since none of us knew
he was even sick,
it was so much
for everyone included.
It was, you know, all the way
from Ryan to the cast,
all the producers.
So, you know,
right before the first day,
they took us to his grave site,
and we all, as a cast,
said goodbye.
We all said our goodbye
and, like, told stories of,
you know, what he meant to us
and started the show and bonded.
And even though we'd all be
grieving on different days,
it was good to know
that you kind of had
a community around you that
could pick you up on that day.
And when the other person's
grieving on their day,
you pick them up, you know?
So, it helped.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I think people are gonna
enjoy this film, the tribute.
-Yeah.
It is an honorable film.
It is a film
that is the perfect film
for the last three years
of our lives.
We have all lost.
We've all suffered.
We've all felt,
you know, deep grief.
And it's about
coming through that.
[ Applause ]
-We need it.
-Yeah, we all need it.
Do you remember the first time
you worked with Chadwick?
-[ Chuckles ]
Yeah.
So, the first time
I met Chadwick
was the final audition,
the screen test.
And we were going through
the scenes, and they're like,
"We just want to see how you
guys are gonna be together,
like, how you're gonna play.
So could you wrestle
or something?
Could you wrestle around?"
And I'm like, "Okay, all right."
[ Laughter ]
"If that's gonna get me this
job, I'm gonna wrestle."
And we start wrestling,
and he's a martial artist,
so he can hold his own.
You know what I mean?
I wrestled, you know,
all through high school
and started a little bit
in college.
And I got in there,
and I, like, crouched down.
And the first thing
that happened
was my pants split open.
[ Laughter ]
I tell you, I have
the best things happen to me.
Let me tell you.
-You really do.
Rihanna and this.
-I'm telling you,
God has a sense of humor.
[ Laughter ]
That is the one thing
I can confirm.
And I'm like --
I'm one of his favorites.
-He does these things.
-How did you know?
Did you hear it?
-Oh, we saw it.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And, you know,
I've always adopted this thing
when it comes to, like,
auditions.
I was like, "You know what?
I don't have to book the job.
I just have to win the room.
If I know I win the room,
they'll invite me back someday."
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-So I always go in places and I
say, "I need to win the room."
And when I split my pants,
I was like, "I'm winning."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I was like, "I'm winning."
-No one else did that.
-No one else did this!
Yeah, think about it.
You took it to the next level.
-I said, at least --
for the least,
if I don't get this job --
and I said that to them
right then and there.
I was like,
"You guys are gonna
have to buy me new pants."
[ Laughter ]
-And, uh, yeah, like...
-I would be intimidated by you.
I mean, you're a big guy.
-You know, but I can be gentle.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Have you ever wrestled?
-No.
-Never?
-Have I wrestled?
-Yeah, like in high school?
-Yeah, thumb wrestling.
Yeah, I was
on the thumb wrestling --
No, I would never wrestle.
-So you don't know any moves?
-I don't have any moves, no.
-I can show you a move
if you need,
if you'd like
to see a little bit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know what?
I think we're gonna go
with the audience.
-I'm good.
-The audience wants to see --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The audience...
[ Cheering continues ]
The audience wants to see
Jimmy Fallon wrestle.
-But I don't want
to wrestle you, though, bud.
You're gonna show me a move
just in case I get in --
If I get in trouble somewhere,
I can do this move.
-Okay, so if a guy
is trying to, like, you know --
Get in your posture.
You might come down. Right?
-Okay, yeah, come down.
-Crouch down.
-Yeah, of course.
This is what I do.
-Like, you can't get in these.
-Okay, yep.
You can't -- yep.
[ Laughter ]
-Right. So, I'm gonna show you
a gentle arm slide.
-Okay.
Arm slide, yep.
-Into a full Nelson.
[ Laughter ]
-That sounds too much.
-So, boom.
You've got a little arm control.
[ Laughter ]
See that?
-Yes.
-I'm gonna come under the arm.
-Yeah, I just --
Right there, so you win.
-Pull you by.
-Okay, yeah.
-Boom.
-Yeah, like that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you still intact?
-Yeah, that was great.
-Okay.
-That was actually good.
That was good right there.
-Now let's try for real.
Come on, come on,
come on, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Grunts ]
-Pfft! Pfft!
[ Laughs ]
You made it.
-I made it, I made it.
-You made it.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Winston Duke
in "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever"!
Take a look.
-Yes!
♪♪
[ Screaming ]
-[ Grunts ]
♪♪
[ Screaming ]
[ Grunts ]
Yaah!
-[ Screams ]
[ Grunting ]
-Yeah!
It's Winston Duke!
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
is in theaters and IMAX
November 11th.
We've got stand-up
from Caroline Rhea
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.